[Musique]
bonjour ça va oui ça va très bien aussi
pour moi je
laisse les pourquoi un rendez vous chez
dolls je pense à merde place pour manger
un cheesecake de sylvie yorkais se
serait add-ons ou un genre de
delicatessen où ça fait partie du repas
depuis son ouverture en 1927 le
delicatessen donne ce famous à montréal
propose la même recette de gâteau au
fromage
il ya beaucoup de mémoire associé avec
notre fric on voit souvent du monde qui
est lente souples en daim cheesecake
classique ou revisiter le gâteau au
fromage a toujours des adeptes les gens
s'en foutent cheesecake on a juste à
regarder les gens qui font la queue pour
manger ou cheesecake factory en floride
à toronto
ou s'il ya tellement de choix maintenant
dans tout ce qu il ya des risques avec
des orignaux au beurre de pinottes gomme
balloune il ya des fois des biscuits au
fond au lieu du big three g
nous on est reconnus pour nos 30 savant
de mini gâteaux au fromage ni à noter
leur caramel fleur de sel ferme bros
caramel il ya les citrons merengues qui
lane depuis le ferais cela ce qui est
toujours celle qui vend du plus antoniuk
aisés les propriétaires du christ kemboi
dans le quartier sainte-rose à laval
offre depuis 2015 une version petit
format à ses clients
l'idée a commencé à en pleurer on a été
mangé un cheesecake factory
au début on faisait à peu près 4 à 500
par jour aujourd'hui on a fait à peu
près 1500 1800 par jour les japonais ont
aussi leur version du gâteau au fromage
saint jean de gâteau au fromage souffler
c'est une autre chose mais c'est du
cheesecake
saucisses
et comme on l'imaginé merci beaucoup ça
c'est le cheesecake de délicatesse
vraiment c'est new yorkais c'est le
cheese cake on connaît à montréal mais
c'est vraiment les anglais qui ont
commencé à faire des tchèques avec ce
fromage en grain mais j'ai tout risqué
date des grecs et aussi des romains et
quand les jeunes d'europe de l'est on
arrivait en numérique ils ont décidé de
prendre le fromage en grain l'identique
qui ressemblait vraiment à leur fromage
qu'ils avaient en europe si tu es de
culture juive surtout quelques retours
de culture juive ils ont mis les
recettes avec eux autant les bugs que le
smoke meat tout ça bien ensemble vous
pourriez pas décidé d'arrêter part du
gâteau au fromage jamais jamais sain
possible c'est comme dire que l'on va
arrêter de faire du sprit
[Musique]
nous avons demandé à l'enseignante en
pâtisserie isabelle sauriol de nous
cuisiner le gâteau au fromage
pour moi le gâteau au fromage d'un
plaider coupable on sait que ces riches
mais c'est bon quand y en a chez menu on
peut pas ne pas en manger est ce que
vous considérez que c'est un dessert qui
est complexe à réaliser
pas tout à fait on pense que c'est
compliqué c'est juste que c'est long à
préparer faut s'y prendre d'avancé donc
dessus pour faire la recette originale
le new york times la croque doit être de
chapelure de biscuits g on veut un fonds
de g quelque chose qui goûte à goûte le
barça goûte le grain mais un petit côté
sel dans la croûte offert
pour faire la pareille date ou fromage
et le fromage à la crème et le fromage y
en a quand même épais faut que ce soit
crémeux donc tu je verse une partie
dessus
on ajoute le reste du sucre la vanille
la crème la crème sur le jus de citron
une touche de zestes d'agrumes qu'élise
on va en tournée pour à peu près une
heure et demie un plat contenant de
l'eau dans le four avec une cuisson à
basse température 82 celsius évitera que
le gâteau nécessaire il faut quand même
qu'ils aient atteint au minimum 65 110
degrés il faut pas que ça dépasse 85
je compense le coût total si on ne fait
pas le couteau il va faire un cru
après une nuit au frigo l'heure de la
décoration a sonné c'est à l'infini l'on
peut partir dans tout les sens mais là
si on veut respecter la nature du
fromage c'est bon avec des fruits on met
notre coup lyon mais les fruits frais de
super séries ont vraiment massacré cette
oeuvre dans on va redonner un quai
à la vie à la vie
[Musique]
c'est tellement soyeux parce que parfois
on mange des gâteaux au fromage c'est
comme sec ou l eau on est loin de ce
nuage de fraîcheur de sucre de savoir
beaucoup de fromages et beaucoup de
bonheur
ouah ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas
mangé chez celles qui ce qu'est et c'est
bon
je suis sûr que tout le monde à la
maison nous regarde en ce moment puis
nous envie
[Musique]